a dock that's a projector for your
Nintendo switch sounds like a sweet idea
right
well the crowdfunded Ojo projector is
exactly that and we had some hands-on
time with a feature complete prototype
thanks to the creators yes Oh Joe and we
have some thoughts on what it does right
and where it can be better
[Music]
first question to address is how good is
the actual projector
well the Oh Joe uses DMD LED tech from
Texas Instruments which provides 200
lumens of brightness from our experience
this isn't all that bright unless the
room you're in is quite dark it'd be
hard to figure out exactly what's going
on in game especially if the game
environment is dark the front of the
projectors pulled back the dimmer the
image will be just by nature of
dispersing the concentration of light
it's said to be able to project between
30 inches and 120 inches of screen space
at about 3 feet away
I had a roughly 30 inch image with
decent brightness pulling it back to
around 10 feet gave me a much bigger
image but things got a little hazy it's
also fairly low res at 854 by 480 a 16
by 9 aspect ratio games are certainly
playable at this resolution but details
are hard to make out in certain games
the text and zelda breath of the wild
was a bit tough to read and at night the
world is tough to navigate but under the
right conditions the projector can look
just fine if you're not too concerned
with visual fidelity I suppose it's
intended for more party oriented games
seeing as how the Ojo isn't ideal for
games that require more attention to
detail like Zelda though Jo has a ton of
bells and whistles though it's
battery-powered so it doesn't need to be
plugged in to use it charges through USB
C and can even use the normal switch
dock plug the projector itself can last
up to 5 hours on a full charge and can
even be set in a charge mode which will
juice up your switches battery about 3
times over with its hdmi in port you can
even use other devices if you wish you
also got two USB 3.0 ports and a 3.5
millimeter aux connection to use
headphones or other external audio
devices if not the ojos 5 watt speaker
can be pretty loud and sounds decent
despite coming out of a small device its
cooling system seemed to keep the switch
and the projector quite cool and didn't
get very loud
the Ojo projector is a neat idea with
plenty of well-thought-out features to
complement it but at its core it
displays switch games at a larger format
which is where it comes up a bit short
with the brighter screen and sharper
resolution it could really shine
but for now you'd have to find the right
conditions to be able to use it
optimally mojo projector made his
crowdfunding goal in IndieGoGo last
month and early bird packs are still
available for 300 bucks units our plan
to ship out in December
stick the game spot for coverage on
switch games accessories and news since
we have plenty more on the way thanks
for watching